first of the bone it's driving itself
it feels good so BMW brought me to the
Consumer Electronics Show here in Las
Vegas I'm going to check out the future
of driving did I get it
am i near all right oh I felt it ha ha
ha that really felt like pushing a
button in this concept car there's a
holographic menu screen
it works by projecting an image above
this panel and then it uses this camera
here in the steering column to determine
where your finger is and when it detects
your fingers in the right spot it uses
ultrasound from these speakers to
provide haptic feedback you can actually
feel it in your fingers it's like a
little buzzing but what I really want to
try is not driving I can actually talk
to the camera are you exactly are you
sure this is a good idea so here's a
question how much should you trust an
autonomous car this car is now driving
itself but I need to be ready to take
over at any time I'm still legally
responsible if something happens to the
car right now but in the coming years
cars are going to take over more and
more of the responsibility for driving
safely and that has led a lot of people
to consider the moral dilemmas faced
when programming self-driving cars the
question is what sort of ethical
framework should we program in through
autonomous vehicles so it needs to make
a decision worth less - entebbe or
swerve right into a motorcycle ok so we
can imagine a lot of weird situations
where an autonomous car has to make a
tough choice but the real moral dilemma
is accidents are happening right now
more than 30,000
each year in the US alone and more than
2 million are injured and the problem in
94% of collisions is driver error in
2015 half of all traffic fatalities
occurred on highways so even this level
of technology we've demonstrated today
autonomous driving on a highway could
save a lot of lives
we are already shirking our
responsibility for driving cars we're
using our phone in 2014 distracted
driving resulted in at least three
thousand killed and four hundred and
thirty thousand injured so if we're not
driving we better hope that the tech
gets to a level where the cars can drive
for us my view this problem is only
going to get worse
you know when elevators became
autonomous a lot of people were
uncomfortable with that they were used
to there being a driver in the elevator
so compromises had to be made like big
red stop button just makes people
comfortable and a nice soothing voice to
say which floor would you like to go to
now I know that elevators have many
fewer degrees of freedom than a car but
even if you look at something like
airplanes airplanes flying in full
autonomous mode are actually safer
studies show then when pilots can take
control I think the moral dilemmas over
exactly how cars should react in the
tiny percentage of cases where tough
choices need to be made is a distraction
from the main problem the longer we wait
to get autonomous vehicles on the road
the more people will die and that is the
real moral question of autonomous cars
why aren't we getting them on the road
faster I hope you enjoyed the run that
was cool now let's
perfect boy
[Music]